You know, I'm here because we're doing a, we're recording a new smartless. And what you can't see is that every time I say smartless, I'm just going off mic on the L into the ESS, so I go smartless. Because it can make you, you can try it at home. Sometimes that out into the ES, you can get a little click into it, right? Like, if you say the word models, you want to just you I just go off or you don't want to you don't want to explode on your P you don't have the plosions so if you're gonna say that's perfect What you can't I just go perfect just off to the side of the mic so I don't go
Perfect anyway. We're a little into the weeds. We're a little inside baseball on the V.O. World But I tell you what we are not. We are not afraid to give you an all new smartness. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart.
Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart.
Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Hey smart listeners, before we get into the good stuff, how about a little great stuff from Shawnee Hayes? Go Shawne. Hey smart listeners, this episode is brought to you in part by our friends at Verizon. If you're wishing for the new iPhone 15 Pro with titanium, you don't need to find a genie in a bottle or, I don't know, steal an unsuspecting kid's birthday wish.
I get it. Verizon is making it easy to get apples latest and greatest with an amazing trade-in offer, even if your current iPhone has seen better days. Sean. Me, my phone is pristine, but you know some of us just aren't as careful. No judgment here.
And look, you know Sean and I are well acquainted with the excellent service and offerings from Verizon, so believe me when I say, this upgrade deal is one for the books. Trade in any iPhone, any model, any condition, for the new iPhone 15 Pro with titanium with unlimited ultimate plan, 100% guaranteed, only on Verizon and network you can rely on. Visit a Verizon store or Verizon.com for full details. Offerance October 18th, 2023, and it's only available in the United States. Now, onto the show. So, uh, listener, you're a part of a double reboot episode.
Um, yeah, we had two reboots. Both Will and I had to reboot this morning. Yeah. Which you are the reboot champ of our trio. I'm, yeah. For some reason, my computer is always the one that's a little, you know, it's a Dell. I love her. Great musician, bad computers.
Yeah. I want to speak into great musician, great singer. Can I just say that within just recently, we lost a great friend, the great... Jimmy Buffett. Jimmy Buffett, yeah. And it was just such a huge loss and loved the guy. Very close friend to yours. Close friend of the whole family.
Yeah, I knew Jimmy a long time. I mean, we weren't best friends, but he was, we were definitely good friends and good family friends. loved the guy and- Very close friend to yours. Close friend of the whole family. Yeah, I knew Jimmy a long time. I mean, we weren't best friends, but he was, we were definitely good friends and good family friends in the kids and everybody. And in my, you know, obviously my heart goes out to Delaney and Savannah and Cameron and my dear friend Jimmy's wife, Jane.
Love the moral. I'll second that. Yeah, you guys know Jane, just one of the all-time greats. She's great. Yeah, super sad. Super sad. Yeah, sorry about that. And a huge, huge loss.
What an awesome guy apart from being an incredible singer, songwriter, just a big-hearted guy. Yeah, he's one of those guys, too, that you hear after how many friends he had. He was like, oh my God, everybody knew him, everybody loved him. Yeah, he was the most generous kind dude. And I've so many memories of him being really generous and kind, not just to me, but to my kids, especially the big kids got spent a long time with him.
Yeah, just a great example of a person that I'm sure that since this was tragically not sudden, he had time to review, I'm sure, of how he's used his years. And talk about, you know, we're all going, we're all leaving. Yeah. So like, what do you do while you're here? And how do you help people and help your family?
And, and, and utilize your uniqueness, you know, there's only one of everybody. So he seemed to really be a poster child for that. One of the, one of the all time greats. And so, we love you, Jimmy, and we miss you already, but you are not forgotten, my friend. I love that. Yep. So right before we get to our guest, Sean,
quickly, how are you finding your first week back from the Tabasco Theater? I mean, are you enjoying being home in LA, revisiting with your sheets, your pillows? Yes, oh my God, it's so nice. My body still thinks I need to be somewhere and perform, but I'm almost over it. Yeah, I'm about to call me,
because I know they wanted to do more of that call me and they said, listen, and they said, you know, Sean's leaving, but would you ever consider it? And I said, and I said, you mean coming to do Oscar Delavent? And they said, forget it, we got the wrong number. Ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, And they said, now, forget it, we got the wrong number. It sounds just like Oscar De La VIII.
No, I'm good. I'm happy. You mean Mario, Mario, brother. You don't take a lot of adjusting to get back into kind of just doing I do actually. I'm pretty tired. I'm, I mean, I've energy, but I'm happy. You got to the house where your slippers happen to see you. They greeted me with open arms. I put them right on. How's Ricky? How's Ricky doing? Good. Everything's good. It is weird.
That's the dog Tracy. What's that? I was just telling Tracy that that's a dog. What Tracy knows? Tracy knows the dog. If there's one thing she, she's the aunt. Yeah. No, I'm, I'm excited. Everything's one thing she, yeah. She's the aunt. Yeah. No, I'm excited. Everything's good. Everything's good. Everything's back to normal.
It's like I was gone today. Jason's getting ready for his intro. He's still doing some copy and paste thing. No, I'm doing, I'm in a deep sweat here trying to, because of the reboot listener. Remember we talked about the reboot. Lost my notes, stirring the reboot, but I just pulled them up out of the bin.
Great. Guest, you're safe. Okay, guest. Guest. Here we go. Here we go. We got a real superhero this morning, guys. Mm-hmm.
Our guest today is without dispute, one of the best athletes the world has ever seen. This is my department. And his sport of football, you might be the best we'll ever see. Wow. He is the NFL's only five time most valuable player. He's a 14 time pro ball selection.
It's Peyton and he. He's the first to win a Super Bowl with two different teams. He's been inducted to the Hall of Fame. And he has more individual records than we got time to mention. It's the Lies brother. It's the Lies brother. It's the Lies brother. It's the Lies brother.
It's the Lies brother. It's the Lies brother. It's the Lies brother. It's the Lies brother. It's the Lies brother. It's the Lies brother. It's the Lies brother. It's the Lies brother. It's the Lies brother. It's the Lies brother. It's the Lies brother. It's the Lies brother. It's the Lies brother. It's the Lies brother. It's the Lies brother. It's the Lies brother. It's the Lies brother. It's the Lies brother. It's the Lies brother. It's the Lies brother. It's the Lies brother. It's the Lies brother. It's the Lies brother. It's the Lies brother. It's the Lies brother. It's the Lies brother. It's the Lies brother. It's the Lies brother. It's the Lies brother. It's thelyse brother. It's Elyse brother. It's Elyse brother. It's Elyse brother. It's Elyse brother. It's Elyse brother.
It's Elyse brother. It's Elyse brother. It's Elyse brother. It's Elyse brother. It's Elyse brother. It's Elyse brother. It's Elyse brother. It's Elyse brother. It's Elyse brother. It's Elyse brother. It's Elyse brother. It's Elyse brother. It's Elyse brother. It's Elyse brother. It's Elyse brother. It's Elyse brother. It's Elyse brother. It's Elyse brother. It's Elyse brother. It's Elyse brother. It's Elyse brother. It's Elyse brother. It's Elyse brother. It's Elyse brother. It's Elyse brother. It's Elyse brother. It's Elyse brother. It's Elyse brother. It's Elyse brother. It's Elyse brother. It's Elyse brother. It's Elyse brother. It's Elyse brother. It's Elyse brother. It's Elyse brother. It's Elyse brother. It's Elyse brother. It's Elyse brother. It's Elyse brother. It's Elyse brother. It professor at his alma mater. Please welcome Will. Paid meeting. I mean, come on. The sheriff is here.
Hi, Paid. You said five time. You said five time. Yeah, there's like, there's nobody left. Yeah. Oh, did you have it guest, Sean? I did. Sean had it. Part the intro. Paidon, first of all, I, of all, I've said this a lot over the years. From the first time I saw you on a sketch program of which I'm not going to mention, and throughout all the number of commercials you've done and things you've done, I have, and I don't want to embarrass you, Peyton, I think you're the best actor, athlete of all time. Of all time. I have a whole lot of time.
All the fame. All the fame. Awesome timing. And that's not a thin category. It the time. All the fame. Awesome. And that's not a thin category. It's not. It's a big category. And I say this not to embarrass you. Talk us a little bit how the man and cast started because I love that you guys ended up doing
it and that you're on TV every week, you and your brother. Yeah, he's awesome. How did that come about? What was the thing that you guys were like, oh shit, did somebody come to you or are you like, you like, we should be, we should be supporting our junk on TV every week. Well, yeah, it's funny because you hate to say anything good, you know, came out of the pandemic, but obviously there was a lot of things being done remotely during the pandemic, including broadcasting certainly.
And so I've been in talks with the, the doing the traditional broadcasting, right? Which I don't think people understand what that really entails, right? The Chris Collins words, the late John Madden who really created it, it is go to the town where the game is on Friday, watch practice, interview the home team, Saturday,
visit with the visiting team coming in, and then sit around all day Sunday or Sunday night, or even Monday to do the game. And then when you get back home, you're really not home because you better be studying where the left guard went to high school. And what is 40 time is. I mean, you have to know more than a quarterback would,
quarterback just hasn't know the defense, right? A broadcaster, you got to know special teams, you got to know more than a quarterback would. quarterback just hasn't know the defense, right? A broadcaster, you got to know special teams. You got to know the depth chart. And so anyway, that's the, so that's what I did not want to do because I got young kids playing sports, wanted to be there on the weekends. My dad was at my youth basketball games,
P.W. football games, those kind of things. So that was the priority. And then, so I kind of approached the ESPN. I was like, you know, P.W. football games, those kind of things. So that was the priority. And then, so I kind of approached the SP and I was like, you know, I saw the remote things. That going to continue. I could get my brother. He's unemployed. I could get him, you know, kind of into the mix. I mean, literally, Eli, I mean, he literally thought they were joking. He's like, wait a minute, they're going to pay me to watch football with my brother from my home in New Jersey. He's like, yes, I know I went to Ole Miss, but I'm still smart of nothing though. That's a good deal. I will do that. That's how the whole family will. That's amazing. That's how it came about. And so, look, we feel like we are at a bar
or on the couch watching the game together, which we would be doing anyway. And the viewers sitting there with us and our guests, they have to love football. Well, that's the number one criteria. You got to love football. And what's cool to me. We'll call it in, right? I'm supposed to call in.
Yeah, we'd love to have it. We'd love to have all of it. I mean, now that Sean's an expert, you know, get a picker on the spread. Yeah, but also, but Peyton, I used to play football when I was a kid. Which is critical, which is critical to being wanted. You have to have played flag as a third grader to get on. No, no, I was tackle football. Really?
Sean, you're dead. You're dead watch your games. I heard it through the rearview mirror, right? I was driving away. A lot of stuff. A few of you. Hey, as he was driving with Sean A lot of stuff. Few of you. As he was driving with Sean's family, Sean's dad famously left his family.
Top speed. You know, it's funny, we started, we started a smartness during the pandemic as well. And we can't believe that anybody would want to sit around and listen to us, just shoot the shit. It seems ridiculous. Even today. It's shocking. It seems ridiculous even today. It's shocking. It's just, you know, it's different. And I think people, like I said, I think when the
game's good, we're talking about the game and the game's not so good, nobody wants to hear about the third and one run play and what defense they were playing when it was a one-yard game. Like, who cares? Let's talk to, you know, Condoleezza Rice about why she likes football. So, I think the cool thing about it, Will, is that there's so many people from different backgrounds. I mean, we had President Obama last year, Condoleezza Rice Snoop Dogg is a huge football thing. He's been a youth football coach in LA for years. And you know Snoop Dogg is? Yes, I do. I do know that Snoop Dogg is., you know, I mean, it's like it, it just brings people together, which I think, which
is cool thing about football. And it doesn't matter what your background is or where you came from. I love football. Liverpool is my favorite team. And I watch every Saturday. And this timed out perfectly, right, Peyton, because staying at home, your kids are, your kids, are your kids 13? Yeah, they're 12th, 12, seventh grade and yeah, I mean, boy and girl twins. Like literally Monday, my daughter has a volleyball game at four o'clock mountain time that
I'll go to. And then at five, I'll drive over to my buddy Scott's garage, which is where I film it. And do the show at 615 and I'm home at nine thirty. So how did Scott, wait, how did Scott, how did Scott's house turn into this dude? Great quick story, you know, Scott owed me a favor. When you went a football game as a quarterback, you have about 50 texts after a game.
When you lose, you have three. Your wife says she loves you. Your dad who played says, hey, tough night, I'm proud of you. Hang in there. Your other brother was a quarterback played says, hey, tough night, I'm proud of you, hang in there. Your other brother was a quarterback, Eli, hey, you know, some tough conditions, you know, get them next week. What you don't do when a quarterback loses is replay the game in the text. Like, you don't say, hey, really sorry about those four interceptions.
Yes, thank you. I remember I was there. It was 20 minutes ago. My friend, Scott, you know, we've all done this. Have you ever texted someone? Accidentally you're talking about them and you text the person that you're talking about? Yes, I think your interceptions against the Bengals one night I come in. I got four texts my dad my brother my wife. I have a fourth from Scott who text says hey Do you think Peyton has money on this game? Okay?
I mean, we both have been there, right? Do I respond? No, do I know it's an accident? Yes. Does Scott call me on Thursday to say, hey, my 10 year old was playing with my phone if you got a weird text? I'm like, all right, Scott,
if that you blamed your 10 year old son, now I have a problem with it. So 10 years later, I said, I said, dirt bad. Yes, it that you blamed your 10 year old son, now I have a problem with it. So 10 years later, I need your garage, okay? You owe me. That was mental trauma. So I'm using your garage. And that's how it came about.
No. Now, wait, no, Peyton, do you just not have the space in your studio apartment that you live in? Yes, it's tight corners in there. The equipment, I didn't know this stays there all year. I thought it was was like we're gonna pop in and we'll pop out when we come back in a couple weeks You only we only do 10 games by the way. We don't do all 17. I don't want to see Eli 17 weeks in a row via zoom And so that equipment staying there year-round didn't excite
Ashley we were doing a little house construction. So that's why I called Scott garage Eli does it from his back house in New Jersey Scott's got an extra man cave, right? He does he does which is not a not a cool word to use on TV So we say garage. Yeah, it's not a yeah exactly Jason. How dare you there might be some good tax implications for Scott too I imagine that we I don't really know what what he gets out of it He wants to come like before the game. I don't let him what he gets out of it. He wants to come like before the game. I don't let him come, I'm gonna come like twice, two out of the 10 games, he gets to come by.
Which I think is coming to his own crowd. He needs to vacate his home. Does he have children or pads? He does it, he does it live there. You know, at least that I know, he's a car collector, but that's where it is. But yeah, I think two games is plenty. It's good.
You got to get him on. You got to get him on. Oh, God, but he liked that. He would like that so much. He obviously likes football, because he was watching that Bingham's game in the fourth quarter after an already thrown four in reception. So it's clear that he's a fan.
That is so good. We'll be right back. Smartless is sponsored by Better Help. Okay. You know, there have been times where I knew that stuff was going on and even though my sort of intellectually I could understand that I was going through something, it was still tough for me to reconcile things. Like, I just like dwell on like some part of my life that wasn't amazing.
And it would threaten to kind of upset the whole apple cart, if you will. And it's like that idea of like, do you ever feel like your brain is getting in its own way? And for me, I do. And therapy was the thing that eliminated that or helped me move through that. You know, it's like that thing of like what you know what you should do, what's good for you, but you just can't do it.
And I don't know, therapy helps you figure out what's holding you back so you can work for yourself instead of against yourself. Give better help a try. It's entirely online designed to be convenient and flexible and suited to your schedule. All you got to do is fill out a questionnaire and you get matched to a licensed therapist. And you can switch therapists at any time for no additional charge. So make your brain your friend with better help. Visit betterhelp.com slash smartless today
to get 10% off your first month. That's betterhelp. H-E-L-P. dot com slash smartless. Thanks to Viori clothing for supporting the show. Viori makes premium performance apparel inspired by the act of coastal California lifestyle and you know, it's an integration of fitness
and surf and sport and art and all this stuff, you know, designed to work out in, but doesn't feel or look like it, which I get and they do a really good job of that, but what they don't mention is, and all those things, they're not like, also made for podcasting. Viori're not like also made for podcasting. Viewers close are really good for podcasting, okay?
You want to sit in a stuffy studio and you want to wear a pair of shorts that are gonna feel like crap, you know? They got your fucking nuts all twisted up. Or do you want to be in a core short? You want to feel comfortable and a short that moves the way that you move, and that you know as soon as you get out of this podcast
that you're gonna go and you're gonna hit the streets, you're gonna work out, you're gonna be doing unorthodox stuff, you know, railway ties and waist deep snow and bags of sand, you know? Working out, I'm not like one of these California workout guys in some flimsy gym. I'm doing real guys stuff. I'm street fighting, okay?
I'm climbing trees, okay? I'm chasing bears, they're not chasing me. We've been fans of Viori for a long time. So we're excited to tell you about one of their newest products. The men's core jogger, hold up. It's everything you love about the core short. The same moisture wicking, stretch woven fabric, an interior box brief liner
for the ultimate in-go anywhere comfort. But it's all of that stuff. Now on a jogger. You lucky sons of guns. Viori is an investment in your happiness. For our listener, they're offering 20% off your first purchase. Yeah. Get yourself some of the most comfortable and versatile clothing on the planet of Viori.com slash smartless. That's B-U-O-R-I.com slash smartless. Not only will you receive 20% off
your first purchase, but you'll also enjoy free shipping on any US orders over $75 and free returns. Go to Viori.com slash SmartLess and discover the versatility of Viori clothing. Hey SmartLess listener, this episode is brought to you in part by FanDuel. Score early this NFL season with FanDool America's number one sports book because right now new customers get $150 in bonus bets guaranteed when you place a $5 bet. That's $150 in bonus bets winner lose. If you've been thinking about joining
Fandool, there's no better time to get in on the action. The app is so easy to use. There's a wide range of betting options, including spreads and player props and overunders and more. Here's the thing about using Fandall. It's a great way to bet on the things you like. And I would like to bet on some of the things that I would like. First of all, I wish we could have bet on Sean when he was on Broadway. I wish we could have bet on Sean when he was on Broadway.
Like I wanted to bet on him like tripping and falling. Bet on him going up on one of his pieces of dialogue. Bet on him playing the wrong note when he was on the piano. That would have been fun. But anyway, if you are a fan of doing all these things that I talked about, Fandals the place to do it. So visit fandool.com slash smartless and kick off the NFL season. Fandool official partner of the NFL, 21 plus exclusion supply.
C show notes for full disclaimer. All right, back to the show. So Peyton, when you went, I was curious to what Will was saying before about going from football to going from, you know, football to acting or, you know, just kind of all around personality. What was it like to go, what was it like your first time when someone was like, hey, we want you to do this commercial or this thing or whatever it was, whatever you first thing and how awkward it must have been not being an actor to kind of look at the camera.
Like, this is bizarre. I don't know if I want this. Like, or was it something you wanted and you're like, I can do this. What do I do? You know, what was the feeling like? Yeah, it's never really something that I, I guess, wanted or thought that I was gonna be able to do.
You know, you play quarterback and all of a sudden, you start getting asked to do a few different things. I think I want you to come speak to a school, right? And certainly do interviews. Now, I will say my dad having played a great argument for 14 years, Sean, that helped me, right? I mean, I think my dad helped me as much with things off the field that come with being in a quarterback as opposed to just on the field. I mean, he always said, do your interviews after you lose. Sign autographs. Yeah. And is that something you have to hone
being able to interview and stuff like that? Yeah, I think so. Yeah, I mean, you try to, I still say, uh, and you know too much and he's always still to this day. My dad texts me in Eli at halftime with like a full, you know, grade of the film. Like Peyton, you know, put saying,
uh, good saying, you know, I mean, it's like literally, it's a feel like we're back in kids. quit saying uh, good saying, you know, I mean, it's like literally, it's a feel like we're back in kids. So uh, the commercials, look, um, you know, I remember we'll, you know, saying that to me, people told me, hey, boy, you have good timing.
I'm like, yeah, I try to throw the ball on time, try to hit the receiver out of the break. They're like, no, in commercials. And so I don't really know what that means, but I know that I like to laugh. I know that my brothers made fun of me a lot and I laughed at that and I would dish it back.
I know that in an NFL locker room, Sean, you better have thick skin, you better be able to take it. And so for a football player to take their helmet off and show that they don't take themselves too seriously, I guess that's kind of what I think about. But by no means don't insult acting by saying I'm an actor, right? I'm a ex-joc that can read a script and can say the line in the way I would normally
say it. I think that kind of helps. But you've got an infectious comfort with your own skin that doesn't seem like it's something that's new. That's what I think. I think that is, and Peyton, you said it, I think it is that you get the sense that you don't take yourself too seriously, which is great. And having that ability to be able to laugh at yourself is key to it, especially obviously
in comedy, not that I'm an expert on comedy, but I think that that is a big part of it. Also, you're not unused to pressure situations. You've been in a few. Right. Right. So when they go action, you're like, okay, I mean, I'm shooting a commercial or I'm doing a thing that's, yeah, I was in the fucking super, I went to Super Bulls. Like, yeah, that's a lot of pressure.
I mean, the one thing, and like I said, you know, football is live. And you mentioned a certain show that, you know, it's also live. And I wasn't necessarily that nervous when I did that because I screwed up live so many times. I mean, I think six interceptions against the Chargers one night would have thrown seven easily. Thank God, you're in at a time. And so- I just texted you about that. You did? You remember that game? Yeah. I just want to remind you about those types of things. Yeah, thanks for bringing up all my highlights on this show. And so, you know, I guess when you're used to doing live
and screwing up live, that when you know you can read a line and have a chance to do it again in a commercial, if it doesn't go well, I guess that certainly makes it a little less stressful for me. But I'm pretty coachable, I will say. When the guy says, here's what I want you to say, my Tennessee education goes as far as, at least being able to follow those instructions.
Right, right. I remember that, because I remember when you did that show, and I remember my ex, my ex-wife, Amy, we talked about, we were like, man, I didn't talk to you. I wasn't famous yet then, so nobody wanted to talk, none of the guests wanted to talk to me yet, none of the hosts, but I remember us talking about it at the time and being like, man, he was so good and relaxed. That was what it was, is you were really relaxed.
Yeah, which is cute. I mean, that was easy to be relaxed because I was around some incredibly talented people. I think the favorite part about that particular show was being, I got to go in the huddle with, you know, in a football game, Will, you don't get to have a 12th guy in the huddle, right? You don't get to have a shadow for the day. I'm like, hey, you're in the way. Get out of the, you know, running back's path.
And so, and that deal, I love going behind the ropes in a different field. And so, that's kind of what's been fascinating to me in some of the different things I've gotten to do. But you definitely needed to find a confidence and a sense of peace with being the center of something and being comfortable with basically having the ball. You ask for the ball.
So for the people who don't play football, can you put it in the risk of asking a heavy question early on, can you, what is like the most important thing that your average person should reach down and grab when they're asked to be, to go to show their excellence? What is that part of you that you tap into where you're comfortable in a leadership position
that you have the confidence to execute? That's a really young, is it something that you learned? Yeah, that's a good question, because I think, look, for me, it's because it goes back to kind of preparation. I mean, in football, I couldn't throw it, you know, 80 yards down the field like some of these guys can now. I mean, I think Josh Allen and my homes can literally throw 80 yards on their back foot. Couldn't outrun anybody. If you ever watch me play Sean, you should know that, right? I had a coach tell me once that I couldn't run out of sight in a week.
Right. That was nice. Took me a lot of field with that. But I think it means I'm not fast. And so I was like, I got to not prepare. I got to study more film than them. I got to know my place. And I was seevers and I got to be on the same page more than anybody. And so I think that preparation is served me in these other capacities. Like I am not afraid to ask questions and go, Hey, Amy, like tell me how you want me to say this. You know, tell me what you want me to do. Hey, director, what do I do? My dad used to give me quotes as a kid. And there's a great quote when he gave me when I was in high school
Pittsburgh Steelers head coach Chuck Nol once said pressure is something that you feel only when you don't know what the hell you're doing and Man, that just stuck with me at the time in school, but it applied to football Nervous you bet I got nervous before every game matter of fact, I think it's good to get nervous. It means you care about what happened. The pressure, that's different. I mean, you really haven't done your homework, right? That's a bad feeling. Great.
So I think that's kind of what always served me well. And it kind of helps me in these other ventures that I'm doing in the second chapter. Yeah, because as a quarterback, I mean, the games I watch, it's like that, they're always like Jason just said, you're always the leader. Like you have to have that DNA, that build in order not just to be a great player,
but to lead and by example, right? It takes a certain intelligence too. And I'm sure it's rare that's why there's so many heart, it's hard to find so many things. I'm biased, it's a hard position. Yeah, I mean when you play I think you got to sign up for all of it You got to accept the one it's a big job when you don't win and when you win You got to you know share the credit with others and it's there's no question. It's not for everybody Can I ask a question about a certain play? Sorry Jay and then I'm no good
You know because I really do love football. I've talked to the guys about this. What has the hot, hot, hot beans. Oh, go ahead. And then ask him about Omaha. And why numbers? 23. 46, hike. No, but, you know, I am fascinated by the science of it, like by the talent and the science of you in your brain,
figuring out how hard and fast to throw the ball to reach at a certain distance, a short distance or a long distance or whatever, that fascinates me. And, but dumb, dumb question, just as a stupid spectator. Additional dumb question, I guess. They're all dumb questions. I'm always so curious when there's a play where all of the players are like, you know, stuck together, like the most dense amount of players, you always throw it to that corner when there's all these defense people around the, and then you look from
on TV, you're like, there's eight other guys wide up, like, why did you throw it to the crowded part of the field? You know what I mean? Talking about in general, are you actually saying that to paint that in general? No, like in general, in general. In general. Do you know what I mean? On TV, it always seems like, why do they just throw it to the 17 players that are
around the one-open guy? The open guy. And instead of that. So like the offensive lineman, the big guys, they aren't eligible to catch a pass. So that eliminates those five, right? So the left tackle might be open. But if they're open, well, he looks open, right? Because nobody's guarding him because he's not allowed.
I call him like a Sam. I got a little bit. That's a good idea. And plus Sean wants to know, well, he's not allowed. I call him like I see him. I got a little. That's a good idea. And plus Sean wants to know, well, he's the largest guy. So why wouldn't you throw it to him? He seems like he'd do well with the ball. I'll text my home after this and say, hey, the left guard, I got a feeling he's going to be open tonight.
He gets the Lions. And so I'm saying, that's why you need me. Yeah. I like that. Sean, I don't know how worse. I mean, I'm not as well. but like that thing of like, you know, when players come on, they have to like literally declare their eligibility, right? Like who?
I didn't know that. I didn't know that. At risk of boring everybody, but, you know, like there's an ounce of the rules. Yeah, I mean, there's five linemen that there's a quarterback. So there's that six. There's only five other players that are eligible to catch the pass. There are certain formations that you can line up in where an offensive lineman is eligible, but he has to tell everybody number 75 is eligible.
So the defense hears that and they go, maybe we should just run it. Just run it. Just run it. I love that. I love that. I love that. Hey, Peyton. Um, so obviously football was, you know, a passion of yours and in your dad, Archie, who shares a great name with my son or my son
shares with him. Uh, but did you name Archie after Archie, man? I did not. So do you name Archie after the cartoon? Sure did it. So did you name them after all in the family? No, man, I named them after a Scottish woodcrafter. That's the true story. A guy we used to know, a husband is named sort of good crafter. I forget what a shut the hell up. Ask your question. Ask my question, which was, um, so, you know, football has just dominated your life. It's been, or not damage. It's been such a big part of your life. But I imagine that you're a fan of other sports and I joked about football, about soccer, that the rest of the world calls football. I'm a, I love American football. I'm a massive soccer fan. I'm a massive hockey fan because I'm Canadian. What's your, what's your,
your F1? And F1. Of course. Well, F1 we did. So we did a, I don't know if you guys know, but I did in, in association with Omaha. We did the first one and we're slated to do two more of these Formula One sort of, what do we call them? They're sort of like Manningcast.
All through the broadcast, Megas. Yeah, all through the broadcast. Yeah. Megas. For Formula One races? Yeah. Oh, nice. Yeah, with me and Danny Riccardo, and then he went and took a seat.
He had such a great experience doing it with Will. He went back into racing a week later, which I thought was very telling. He changed the back into out of retirement. And then he broke his hand for Danny. I actually got to take some back. But what other sport other than Formula One, what do you have a sport that you're passionate about other than football? I mean, I play golf, certainly, but look, I love sports.
I love living Denver, so I mean, the nuggets, the avalanche, so I keep up with all of our local sports, grew up playing baseball, but golf would be my one kind of passion. Me and Bateman are looking for a game. He's kind of giving the run around on a tee time. No. So is that true?
It's been tough. It's been tough. Listen, come on. We'll play. I'll play with y'all. I'm much freer than Jason's. Now, Peyton, don't you see golf more as a game as opposed to a sport? Do you draw a distinction there between a game and a sport?
Yeah. Like baseball, I consider a game not a sport. Football, I think, is a sport, basketball, I think game and a sport. Yeah. Yeah. Like baseball, I consider a game, not a sport. Football, I think, is a sport. Basketball, I think, is a sport. Baseball, more of a game. Golf, more of a game. tennis, more of a game. I've never thought about it. I mean, stuff, stuff that's a little bit slower, that's a little bit more sort of, you got to deal a little bit more in long-term strategy as opposed to quick turnaround on plays, scoring opportunities. 10 is a sport that's. Yeah.
I think I don't want to play with Jason now after hearing that. Oh, dude. Can I get out of here? I hear you. So he's so intense. We're in, we're after this. Sounds like a long pre-shot routine. What it sounds like.
Oh, dude, dude, you have no idea. Why'd you do it. You know what it's called? He even admits it's called the process. Oh, it's, it's so the process of it. Let's put it this way. I walk ahead of the group so I can start my process and not you suck up any extra time. You've never seen anybody stand over a ball longer before they actually hit and you think and as a sportsman, you're going to say, how the fuck can you even make, he plays very well, by the way. It's gotten better. Has it not gotten better?
It's gotten better. It has gotten better. I think I'd rather watch football with Sean and complain about they're not throwing to the lineman and then play golf in the same basement. I need a shot clock in golf. I think I do well with that. Sounds like it. You have gotten much you have gotten much better though. I will say that you have gotten much better. But I know because you know, I hear Peyton with if you're the if you're a four handicap, you have four swing thoughts. If you're a 20 handicap, you got 20 swing thoughts. So I think I become a little bit better in golf. And so my checklist is smaller. Jason, what are you playing at right now, Jay? My handicap. Yeah. I'm like a, what am I on 11 from the blues at our place. So it's
like a seven index. Yeah. 25 words or less. What's the handicap? Thank you. It's unbelievable. Is it? Exactly. Jason, Jay, you know how you were saying sport and sport in a game. Jason's It's unbelievable, isn't it? It's unbelievable. Jason, you know how you sang sport in a sport in a game? Jason's questions are games. I know. Nice for it. I just love the sound of my voice so much, you guys.
And now, a word from her sponsor. This episode of SmartLess is brought to you in part by Framebridge, the easy and affordable way to custom frame just about anything, and we have. Well, Sean has. And I'm about to look. Framebridge has curated selection of frame styles and design experts to make it fun and easy to choose the perfect frame for your piece. And the process is very simple,
the order online at frameridge.com, either upload a digital photo for them to print and frame, or mail your art in, they'll send you free, secure, prepaid packaging. Framebridge, custom frames your piece using the highest quality materials and ships it to your door for free. So, I know that Sean got two things framed and I'm happy for him.
I really am. I mean, I haven't thought about it a lot, but when I think about it, I'm like, yeah, I'm happy for him. Fine. I have this great photo from when I was over at Anfield, where Liverpool plays. And it's me and Yergen Klopp, obviously. And Pat Linders, he's assistant. And so what I want to do is I want to get those frames so that I can have them in my office, just to kind of remind everybody that I'm a big shot. Anyway, sad as that sounds, I still want to
get it done. I'm excited to do it over at Frame Bridge because it's really easy. I've got the photos. I'm going gonna upload them to them, and then these framed photos of this amazing moments that I experience are gonna come back and I'm gonna have it in my house. Frambridge pricing is fair and transparent. Pricing is based simply upon the size of your piece and you know exactly what you'll pay upfront.
And now they have 19 retail stores in New York City in Boston and Philly and, in Maryland, Virginia, Chicago, Atlanta, so you can get one-on-one expert design advice and see the collection in person. Visit framebridge.com or a local frame bridge store to get started and custom frame just about anything. Thank you to State Farm for supporting this episode. Think of all the amazing things in life that are expressions of just you, for instance.
The song you stream over and over again while you're in your 13th hour of gaming at 4 in the morning with all the lights off trying not to wake up your roommates. Or the recommendations that you share with your friends on the top six comedy podcast that are the best to listen to on your way to the gym and back. Or even your new haircut, which may or may not be an epic bowl cut from the 90s. And hopefully is everything that makes you, you, makes all the difference. State Farm believes insurance should work the same way. Your plan, your coverage selections can be personalized by you
and the ability to choose the plan you want by picking the options that fit you like choosing to bundle your home and auto policies is what the State Farm personal price plan is all about. Getting the coverage you want at an affordable price just for you. So are you ready to make things personal? Call or go to statefarm.com today
to create your state farm personal price plan. Price is vary by state, option selected by customer availability and eligibility may vary. Smart lets get support from Zip Recruiter. You're putting together a team. What do you want? You need people that you can rely on,
people who can do the job that you need to have done. And you don't wanna spend a lot of time worrying about people, you know, doing the job that you hired them to do. You wanna get the right people. You know, for us, you know, we have a whole team behind SmartLess and we need, part of our team, we need people to have the ability to laugh at yourselves, or have as a podcast, we have the loose approach
with the guests and being honest with each other and really getting each other. So we make it seem easy, but building an amazing team is actually pretty challenging. So if you're building a team and need to hire the best people for it, you need Zip Recruiter. And right now, you can try it for free at ziprecruiter.com slash smartless. Zip Recruiter uses smart technology to scan thousands of resumes
to find the most qualified people for your job. Then, Zip Recruiter lets the most qualified people for your job know they are a great match for it to encourage them to apply. Building a solid team is easier than you think with Zipper Cruder. Four out of five employers who post on Zipper Cruder get a quality candidate within the first day. Go to this exclusive web address right now to try Zippercruder 4 free. Zippercruder.com slash smartless. Again, that's zippercruder.com slash S-M-A-R-T-L-E-S-S. Zippercruder, the smartest way to higher. And now back to the show.
I would love being a quarterback just so I could yell and everyone in the stadiums listening to me. Speaking of which, I want, I have a, I bet you've answered this question a million times. I want to know the relevance of Omaha as your audible call. And then also I want to hear what just a, an average play sounds like in the huddle. Okay.
Just tell me what that sounds like. And then tell me what, what, what it all means. What it means. Let's, let's go with the huddle call first. Just tell me what that sounds like. And then tell me what what it all means. What it means. Let's go with the huddle call first. Perfect. All right. Here we go. Let's go explode to gun. Double right flip zebra. Scott left. Why drag F hook. F trail alert. 52 French all easy on two on two. Ready. Break. All right. Come on. We're going to explode means we're going to start in a kind of a tight formation. We're going to explode out to the different formation, right?
We're gonna make the defense react, right? Before the snap. Before the snap, right? We're gonna shift, right? Gun, shotgun, right? Double means we are gonna be in a two guys on each side formation, double, right? Trips would be trips to one side, double.
We're gonna go double right, which means the tight ends gonna be on the right, but we're gonna flip it it and we're going to put the guy who should be on the right with the tight end. He's going to flip to the other side, which is actually going to form a little bunch on the left. We're going to go zebra. That's he's going to go in motion. Zebra is going to tell him to go in motion. Zebra's going to tell the Z to go in and back out. There's zebra motion, right? A little eye candy for the defense, right? Scott left is the passport to show you what the defense is based on how they react to the
motion. It's exactly right. If the cornerback runs with the motion, that tells you it's man to man. If it is kind of bump over, that tells you it's zone. It's called a pre-snap indicator. Scott left is the passport. I see Y drag is telling the wide run of five yard drag across the field. X hook, 12 yard hook by the X. F trail is the F's gonna run a little angle right out of the back field to full back. You have the running back, you got in the back field. And then alert, 52 sprint, Jal easy is,
if the defense is playing soft zone and you don't like it, you go alert alert alert, you've seen Tom Brady, he always says alert alert alert points to us. And you're gonna go to the second play. You're gonna run this draw play to the right to take advantage of the defense. On two, it's gonna be not on one and not on two. It's I mean, not on one.
It's gonna be on two and you're ready break. And so that's when the snow comes. So what if you call it and then what if you yell Omaha at the line, that, that says an audible and how do they know what that new play is exactly. So Omaha was really the word that meant we had changed the play. When you audible Jason, it's usually with like six seconds left, right? Because the defense is disguising the show and blitz.
They're not going to blitz. Obviously you're like, ah, they're not blitzing. Okay, I want to go to that second place. So I'm going to say alert alert alert. And I don't have time to go through a rhythmic cadence, which Sean alluded to earlier with the colors, right? Blue 20, blue 20, HUD hut is a normal cadence. You don't have time to say that with six seconds left. So you go alert alert alert.
Omaha set hut, right? It tells everybody, oh, he's gone to that second play and it's just a few seconds and now we're going to snap the ball. So and you called the second play in that huddle as well. We called the second play in that huddle and we did that's all we did. So I was saying Omaha every single play. So that's how it kind of got connected with me. The microphones got turned up louder and you start a production company You know out of that because of an audible so it was a chain reaction about yelling Ozark I think that that would have that would have popped through a little bit better
It's funny. It's funny. You say that because it's a good way to get your you know Your show your business viral marketing if you can get it into a quarterback snap cat Yeah, three syllables is kind of what it needs to be. It's rhythmic, right? Ozark would be jerky, right? And somebody might flinch. It is. Well, it was filled with jerks.
It was filled with jerks. You know, will our net has got a good little, you know, flow to, what about an Audi e-tron? Audi e-tron. Audi e-tron. That sounds so forth. That's awesome. We are professional grade. We are professional grade. We are professional grade.
You know what the other thing you can do? You can just, you can just, it's your KJK, like just kidding about the first, JK, JK, JK. That means you got it. Wait, I would, first of all, I would kill to write the new Lingo for the, for the Huddle. I would kill the right those words.
Hey, do you hear my shunts, new gig? I would start with, okay, ready? You guys hear my shunts, new gig? Yeah, I write, I write lingo for the huddle. It'll also be, it'll start with, okay, guess what? Or here goes. Here goes, we got two jobs in a cuff on the side with a lemon twist. And instead of a hot hot hot, it would be five, six, seven, eight, and then they would snap it.
Okay, so wait, that blows my mind all that chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin chin I haven't asked one question yet. Go ahead, Sean. I know. So I think that's all fascinating to me. Is it obviously different teams have different lingo, right? They don't use similar languages, different languages. That's one of quarterback's change teams. It's hard to learn. The new vocabulary, Aaron Rogers, is going to the jets this year, but he's got his call in the plays, came from Green Bay. So Aaron knows the language, he knows the verbiage. so he's going to be able to play fast and play well learning a new system is hard it takes time yeah and so that's a huge advantage for for the Jess this year.
What would you do if another quarterback started yelling Omaha as they're as they're audible barking? I I I've sent him my address I expect to check to check, you know, like a kind of cool guy on a letter of a lawyer, a little bit of passion on that, yes. Exactly. I've always wondered about this, because we do it a little bit. We're kind of carnies doing what we do, and that we move around a bunch, and you know, sometimes it sort of coincides with the school year or whatever, and kids and all that
stuff. You start out, you're a single young man right out of college You go pro you have very successful career then you get married and then you have kids What is that life like as you're sort of the latter half of your career and your kids are growing up and you're on the road and stuff At the risk of getting two personal just what was that dynamic like and being an athlete and you've got to take care of yourself, you've got to manage your sleep, you've got to manage your diet. How does that fit in with the home life?
Yeah, it's funny. You know, football is pretty good on travel, right? And I think people completely different than basketball or baseball. Football, you travel Saturday eight times a year, right? Just eight row games and you're back home Sunday after the game. You know, baseball. You're spending four nights in the town, basketball, you know, you're on the road. So football is actually is pretty good from that standpoint.
We didn't have kids until basically we got the Denver toward the last half of my career. But yeah, I do think it's a challenge to look quarterback. This they say, you know, some people say I can't take it home with me. I think they're paying you to take it home with you. I think you got to really, you know, organize your time and your schedule. Hey, I'm on Tuesdays. My off day, I'm going to, you know, you know, plan these things with my, with my young kids or do some charity work, but I think kind of writing out your schedule
kind of helps quarterbacks, right? But certainly a lot of film study, a lot of things on your own. But from a family standpoint, you know, playing the NFL is actually pretty good. Yeah, interesting. So like when you, and you're used to it, because obviously again, your dad played for 14 years in NFL, so you kind of, you've seen it from both sides.
Yeah, no, and my dad was a great, included us, you know, me and my brother, Cooper got to go to the practices on Saturdays, you know, got to go down the locker room after games. And so, you know, I think you see more quarterbacks, including their young kids and people in their lives, right? Cursons. In this quarterback show, we did, you know, head as kids in the locker room. So I can relate to that, and I love including my kids
and some of the cool things of that I get to do. That's cool. What was the tension like when you were getting close to saying yes to Tennessee and not going to Ole Miss? Did you try for Ole Miss? Yeah.
Because Peyton's dad went to Ole Miss, it was a big deal there, and then you were no slouch coming up. So what was that decision process going? It was Ole Miss interested? Yeah, they were interested. I was interested. That's kind of where I wanted to go.
Jason's where I always thought I would go. It's where I only college I ever thought existed for the majority of my life. And then you start getting recruited and you realize, oh, there are some other schools. And I got to give props to my dad. My dad said, son, you're 17 years old. You can make your own decision here, right? You decide where you want to go and you go there and I'll have your back. And he said, you're going to Ole Miss. That's where I went. That's what we're doing into the discussion. And he actually took some flak from people that he knew, for not making it. For not staring you. his own mother, which which was tough. But
what happened with the first the first time you played old miss? That was awkward for my from my from my parents. It's funny when the coach for Tennessee came to recruit me. That was my mom's number one question. Do y'all play Ole Miss in the next four years? And he says, no, we don't. And it was an absolute lie. We played him twice in those four years, right? Which, back then, like before the internet,
you couldn't really check the future schedules. So how'd you do in those games? We won both, which is probably helpful. But yeah, it was tough. My dad kind of sat on his hands and wore neutral clothes. And, you know, Eli went to Ole Miss. Everybody was happy. Everybody's at peace now.
But like watching, you know, watching your dad play football when you were growing up, obviously, the question is, would you have gone into football? Like, do you just think that's, well, that's what my dad did, that's what I'm gonna do? Or, that's a great question. I think people think I'm going to do. Or that's a great question. I think people think my dad like raised quarterbacks. That was his master plan.
It was actually a complete opposite. He like just raised kids. Like do you think you would have been drawn to it anyway? There's no doubt that I had a real passion for it because I got to grow up around it, right? Did I? Yeah, yeah, yeah. He was my hero, my dad, favorite quarterback, all of that. But it was never a plan.
It was never like, hey, Peyton, we're gonna go run two miles this morning. Like, you know, people used to say, about that, having me watchin' film as a fifth grader, like that is total bullshit. Like, completely made up. And they, you know, I mean, you tried to raise normal kids, and maybe that's why I ended up happening
because it wasn't some master plan, right? And it wasn't forced upon you, yeah. Absolutely not. And dumb question, worst injury ever. I've had neck problems during my time with the Colts and several surgeries that. Oh, really? I must have been scary.
Yeah, because neck takes everything, right? I remember that. I remember that. Yeah, the doctors that I went to, I basically like challenged them to tell me, like, they tell me, I can play anymore. And that's the end of it. Like I will walk away today. I'm not going to, I want to be healthy for the rest of my life. And I mean, they just wouldn't say it. They said, Hey, your neck actually is secure. You have nerve damage in your right arm. So I had weakness. That was
kind of my issue. But you know, I remember the doctor that I trusted most is like, Peyton, if you were my own son, I tell you, you are clear to play. If you get your strength back, you know, you're good doctor that I trusted most, he's like, Peyton, if you were my own son, I'd tell you, you are a clear deploy. If you get your strength back, you're good to go. And so that's kind of what it was for me. By the way, by the way, it should be no sorry, just so we'll stay on the next thing. I'm not kidding. Chappy, Mark Chappellus, my buddy and writing partner in England is a friend of the show.
He literally texted me 10 minutes ago out of the blue. He says, in the end, I decided to have surgery on my problematic muscle in my neck. Oh wow. Dot, dot, dot, I never looked back. Very nice. That's a joke. Thank you, Chad.
Out of the blue. So with you and Eli, kind of boldly going into a lane that your father had already been incredibly successful in, it's just, I think it's really incredible that you guys had the courage to do that, knowing that you're probably going to be unfairly judged, and then had incredible results. Can you talk a little bit about what that process was making that calculation and then what it felt like when you guys did so well? Yeah, I mean, we didn't know how it was going to turn out because there was no kind of
baseline for what we were doing. And I knew doing it with Eli Jason was the only way to do it, right? You talk about chemistry amongst broadcast partners. Like, I know Eli very well. He makes fun of me very well, often a lot. I mean, the forehead jokes, they get a little old. I'm like, get some new material. I think that gave us a chance kind of coming out of the blocks that we see football the same way.
Eli and I used to have these conversations on the bus after a coach or Giants game, and we could just talk about the play from one of our games and I can see it. I didn't have to write it down. He didn't have to screen shot a picture of the defense. I'm like, I got it. And so we still kind of can see it that same way.
But look, I love talking football with people who love football as much as I do. And Snoop Dogg is football. There's a little more smoke coming out of Snoop's Zoom than there is kind of least. But he loves football, so it's all good. So, yeah, look, it's not for everybody. You know, I think people go back and forth between the main broadcast and the B team, which, you know, I think ESPN just wants you watching one of their channels.
But I think one thing is clear that Eli and I are having fun doing it. And so I think if they see us having fun, maybe the viewer has fun as well. So maybe that's why it's worked. But it's a fun way to stay close to the game. But he and I like celebrating the positive accomplish. We're not looking to rip anybody. We'd rather say great play by the defensive back as opposed to what a horrible throw by the quarterback because we've been there, right? We've phoned all those interceptions.
So, you know, that's kind of amazing. So, no, I appreciate it. It's infectious, man. Yeah, it's really good. Keep it up, keep going. Thank you for your time today And maybe we'll see you down the road you can you can watch my process up close and my incredible waggle I can't wait. I can't wait. Thanks for having me guys. All right, thanks. Thanks for coming very kind to me. All right, bye buddy, right
How great is Pete Manning? I mean JB great one. Great guest. Well? I mean, Jamie, great one, great cast. Well, I mean, listen, it's, this is the greatest thing about this podcast. You get to sit there and you get to talk to these heroes. I mean, I fan out on everybody we have on this show. Wow, you get to sit with myself, you're a hero. Well, but the Be Pressing Company definitely excluded.
Oh. You know, you get, when are we gonna to have a chance to talk to Peyton Manning and, and, and I need like a little, little, little boy asking him all these questions? Now that I'm older, I'm actually a fan. Yeah. I was, I was always, always a fan of his, always, always. I just, I love the way he did. And I thought he was really funny.
Um, but B, I love the way he played football. And then see when he did get injured and came back from it and won a Super Bowl, that was fucking rad. Was that the neck? Well, the neck injury. Yeah. Oh, wow. And people were worried, he talked about, I mean, kind of downplayed it, people were worried
about whether he'd be able to throw that well again and stuff. And he would get hit, does that, does that hit, you know? And it just, Sean, it kind of goes to what you were talking about, like having that, whatever that thing is of being a leader. Yeah. Like he's got so much confidence in his own ability to bounce back and not to just walk around, but to bounce back and win a super ball. Yeah.
Yeah. You know exactly how that feels. Yeah. I guess you do. Hey, you know the song, I like short shorts. Does it apply to, I guess, I do you like? I'll show you a short back. Wait, is that underwear?
Is that what we're wearing today? These are my little golf shorts. My little gray ones. So we'll, we're going to wear darker ones today. Yes. Shades, good. Just longer ones. Will and I hosted a couple of friends of ours that are members at another golf course here
in Los Angeles. One of whom's a big friend of the show has done two episodes, a live episode end in studio. And so we'll have the idea that yesterday that we should show up and intimidate them by wearing matching outfits. And so we did. We did. We did.
Blue pants and a white shirt, white shoes white hat. Can you say who it is or no? Unimportant, but now we're going to their course today. Their course allows shorts. So yes, it's that guy. So we're going to wear some shorts today. It looks like well, yes. We're going to wear short.
So these are the light gray. Also have a bit of a darker gray short. Do you have any that are your size? No, they all came in a boy's medium. Yeah. So why don't we rethink the, no, sit back down. We got it. Yep.
And the granemals is that you match the top because they're granemals. I tell you what, Sean, we're going to go. We're going to play and don't worry afterwards. I'm going to give you the full play. Bye. Bye. Play. Well done.
With an assist to Rob Armjav. Rob Armjav. Smiles. Smiles. Smiles. Smiles. Flies. Smartless is 100% organic and artisanally handcrafted by Michael Grant Terry, Rob Armjav,
and Bennett Barberco. Our next episode will be out in a week wherever you listen to podcasts, or you can listen to it right now early early on Amazon music, or early and ad-free by subscribing to Wondry Plus in Apple Podcasts or the Wondry app. I'm Carrie Mulligan, the host of I Hear Fear, a new anthology series of terror. The stories in this podcast are things that people don't want to talk about when the sun's out, and the world's supposed to make sense. But you and I know better, don't we?
We know that the best horror stories are the ones we tell each other in the dark, so turn off your lights and close your eyes. In each episode of Eye Hear Fear, you'll be treated to a new psychological thriller, a forest monster who lures teens into the woods and never lets them return. A line of beauty products that takes the search for youth to dark extremes.
And an EDM party that turns deadly when the DJ takes over more than just the dance mall. Strap in, as these twisted stories and paranormal events take you on a suspenseful and thrilling ride. I hear fear will introduce immersive horror and lead you straight into the heart of darkness. Follow I Hear Fear on the Wondery app or wherever you get your podcast. You can listen to I Hear Fear early in At Free right now by joining Wondery Plus. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.